la bâtisse qu'on peut voir quelle
richesse blanc ces cellules à la maison
des métallos sinistrés deux fois en huit
mois on dirait que la guigne s'acharne
sur la famille arana originaire du
honduras pourtant venu trouver la
sécurité à gatineau en septembre dernier
ils ont tout perdu lorsque leur logement
de la rue jumonville a été soufflé par
la tornade qui a ravagé le secteur mont
bleu quelques membres de la famille ont
même été blessés par les débris de vitre
propulsé dans les airs
oui il a eu paul mon père il était comme
pas la laisser
quand il a vu les taux bas ils étaient
cédés hors il était pas laisser la
famille déménage rue riviera pensants et
trouver la paix la sérénité au bord de
l'eau or la rivière des outaouais est
désormais à quelques centimètres du
rez-de-chaussée on a laissé le tout
l'avant corps et tout perdu encore une
deuxième fois une deuxième fois on a
tout laissé à la maison juste qu'on
pouvait sortir sauvé c'est l'avis de mes
petits frères paix le pape est
importante parce qu'on ne peut pas
perdre nos papiers nationalité alors là
vous êtes sinistrés pour une deuxième
fois quelques mois vous santé mais l'air
g5 1 n'est pas chanceuse mais on est
fort on va parce que tous travaillent
fort pour ça en attendant la famille de
dix vit en tassé dans un petit logement
d'à peine deux chambres espérant pouvoir
regagner la résidence du quartier mont
bleu quand elle sera rénovée et
centriste ils sont déçus parce que les
mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait de mal en
première c'est l'étonnant maintenant
c'est l'inondation mon petit frère et se
rappelle encore de thomas et des houches
je me rappelle les appuis c'était comme
c'était hier des fois ils perdent un
exemple de résilience et d'espoir malgré
la malchance
vas-y notre et roche qui était dans le
chemin
ouais mais en barraient aussi hawaï le
chemin continue pareil
oui
ici martin robert radio-canada gatineau